I'm gonna show you how to make your own vanilla extract at home.
It's easier than you think it is.
These are Grade a Madagascar vanilla extract beans.
Will smell the vanilla through the bag that strong.
And to make vanilla extract,
you just need to soak these vanilla beans in some sort of alcohol.
I'm gonna use vodka today,
and I'm gonna use some pretty cheap vodka
that I just picked up from the package store.
And use Bourbon,
you can use whiskey,
you can use Grey Goose,
you can use the most expensive vodka you can find.
And I've heard Bourbon vanilla extract is really good.
But today I'm just gonna use the cheap vodka.
is gonna extract the essence of the vanilla out of the vanilla bean.
Few ways you can do it.
You can just shove the beans into the bottle,
pour the vodka in,
let it sit for six to eight weeks,
and call it good.
Or you can split the beans open and scrape the vanilla bean paste out,
shove that in with the bottle,
and mix it up with the vodka.
That makes it work a little bit faster,
and then the vanilla essence, or extract,
depending on where you're from,
um, will become darker and more potent.
Uh, you could also do the quick method,
which I'm not gonna do today.
I'm just gonna let mine sit in the bottle for six to eight weeks.
Since I have a lot of Extract already.
But what you can do is put them in a pressure cooker,
and I heard that works really well,
and I'm probably gonna try that out next time, um,
cause I actually wanna see if that works.
But you can put it in a pressure cooker with the vodka and do it for,
you know, pressure it for a few hours and then it's ready to go.
Don't know if that works,
but you can always try.
I put my vanilla extract in these kind of bottles,
and you can see this is how much I've gone through.
I use vanilla extract in pretty much all my cooking around here.
So I'm gonna take these old beans out.
Of course, the little ripping bit didn't work,
so I need to go grab some Scissors.
This is what the beans look like when they come out the bag.
I'm gonna split some of these beans, cause I want them to work faster.
Slice the bean down the middle to open up the inside of the bean.
And that's all that vanilla bean paste in there that we wanna extract.
Let's start putting the beans inside the bottle open.
Gonna leave the rest of these now.
I'm actually going to try the canning method,
so I'm gonna leave some of these back.
I'm just gonna add the vodka.
I as I said, I got this really cheap vodka.
Was around $10, I believe.
Make sure the vanilla bean is completely Covered
and I'm gonna leave a little room at the top
cause I wanna be able to shake the.
The bottle and have the vanilla bean squash around in there.
I'm gonna leave this in the pantry for six weeks now,
and then every week or two, when I walk by and notice she's there,
I'm gonna shake the bottle
and that will help the vanilla bean breakdown.
So you gonna need leave a little room in the top there
so you can shake the bottle and have the beans slush around.
This package of vanilla beans
could probably do two to three bottles at this size
bottle of vanilla extract.
So that's a great savings. If you do a lot of baking,
a lot of cooking with vanilla extract,
I definitely recommend trying this.
This is so easy to make your own.